una imagen que se ha convertido en uno
de los símbolos más poderosos del siglo
20 un manifestante decidió hacerle
frente a una línea de tanques que
irrumpieron en la plaza de tiananmen de
beijing el 4 de junio de 1989 las
protestas de jóvenes en la capital china
llegaron luego de que el gigante
asiático cayera en un caos económico
registros inflacionarios de cerca del
30%
los jóvenes descargaron su enojo contra
la corrupción y el autoritarismo chino
[Aplausos]
con registros de una dura represión 33
años después el hecho se recuerda como
una sangrienta masacre el gobierno chino
ha establecido una fuerte censura sobre
el tema en beijing y las fuerzas de
seguridad de hong kong no permiten
ningún acto conmemorativo desde el 2020
con la llegada del cobi 19
creo que no es sólo este año las
autoridades han tratado de impedir que
la gente conmemora el incidente del 4 de
junio
estoy decepcionado porque aunque nadie
organiza ningún acto conmemorativo las
autoridades ya están en alerta máxima
la asociación de las madres de tiananmen
reiteró este año que se esclarezcan los
hechos del trágico día mientras el
gobierno chino usa toda su autoridad
para que cualquier información de la
matanza de tiananmen desaparezca incluso
de cualquier medio de comunicación
creo que hong kong ha entrado en lo que
yo llamo una época oscura creo que no
sólo prohíbe la conmemoración del 4 de
junio sino también todas las actividades
políticas con opiniones de oposición
el ejército de liberación popular chino
nunca ha hecho público el número de
muertos de la represión pero las
estimaciones de testigos y grupos de
derechos humanos oscilan entre 200 y
2.000 muertos
[Música]